P
IT UP.
LOOKING AT THE SQUAD.
I WILL SAY, THEY FINISH NINTH OR
TINTH IN THE WEST, IT COUNTS AS
A SERIES.
>> IT DOES NOT COUNT AS A
SERIES.
IN FACT, THE NBA DOES NOT COUNT
IT AS THE PLAYOFFS.
THE STATS DON'T EXIST.
THEY GO OFF IN STAT PERURGATORY.
YOU GAVE A QUALIFIER.
I DON'T WANT, ON THIS SHOW,
TAKES WHERE PEOPLE ARE LIKE, IF
ANYBODY'S HEALTHY AND LeBRON
DROPS 40 A GAME -- COME ON.
>> I'M AN OPTIMIST.
THAT MAY NOT HAPPEN AND WE MAY
BE IN CANCUN EARLIER THAN
EXPECTED.
>> WHEN DID DeANDRE HAVE A CHAIN
LIKE THAT.
WOW.
WIN A PLAYOFF SERIES.
I WANT ALL THE TAKES TO BE
REMEMBERED SO THAT IF IT
HAPPENS, I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PLAY THIS CLIP AFTERWARDS AND
GIVE YOU YOUR FLOWERS, JUST LIKE
I WANT FLOWERS.
>> YOU KNOW THAT NBA TWITTER IS
WATCHING THIS.
THEY HAVE CLIPPED OFF THAT CLIP
AND THEY WILL RUN IT MAINLY BAD
THINGS HAPPEN.
IF GOOD THINGS HAPPEN, THEY WILL
FORGET.
MICKY MOUSE RAIN BUBBLE.
WHATEVER THE NEW LeBRON NICKNAME
IS.
YOU WILL NOT HAVE SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THAT IT.
THOSE ARE FUNNY.
BUT SO IS THE RING.
IF YOUR TEAM DID NOT MAKE THE
BUBBLE, HOW DO YOU TACK ABOUT
THE BUBBLE?
WHY DIDN'T YOU WIN THE BUBBLE
CHAMPIONSHIP IF IT WAS SO EASY?
>> THE SUNS I FEEL LIKE WERE
SECOND PLACE.
THEY WERE 8-0 AND DIDN'T PLAY.
YOU MAY THINK YOU ARE BEING A
LITTLE SPICY.
SOMEBODY WAS SPICIER THAN YOU
AND IS DOUBLING DOWN ON YOUR
TAKE.
LET'S GET A TASTE.
>> LeBRON AND A.D. HAVE NOT LOST
A PLAYOFF SERIES TOGETHER AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN THIS
YEAR.
THEY DOMINATED IN 2020 AND THEY
WILL DOMINATE AGAIN THIS YEAR.
THE LAKERS ROSTER PROBLEMS ARE
OVER AND BLOWN.
THE PIECES DON'T MATTER AS MUCH
AS THE SUPERSTARS AND LeBRON AND
ANTHONY DAVIS ARE STILL THE BEST
DUO IN THE WESTERN CONFERENCE.
>> OKAY.
I AM GOING TO SAY ORIGINALITY,
EH.
7.8.
ENERGY, TO ME, THAT WAS LIKE A
6.
I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS A 10 FOR
HIM.
I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS A LOT OF
ENERGY FOR HIM.
SO I'M GOING TO GIVE THAT
TAKE -- THAT TO ME -- I'M GOING
TO BE A HARD JUDGER.
I DON'T LIKE THE DUNK CONTEST
WHEN THEY GO TOO HIGH EARLY ON
THAT'S A FIVE TO ME.
YOU'RE BRINGING UP OLD
STATISTICS.
YOU'RE NOT GIVING ME ANYTHING
KNEW NEW, AND ALSO, I DON'T
AGREE WITH IT.
BUT I FEEL YOU HAVE A MEME CUED
UP.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH, I WANT THAT IN MY EAR
TOO.
DOI HAVE A MEME.
I'M DELUSIONAL.
THAT IS FACTS.
>> FACTS.
>> HE IS CAPPING.
BECAUSE I THINK -- WHEN BOTH ARE
HEALTHY?
THEY LITERALLY LOST TO THE SUNS
LAST YEAR.
THE HAMMY GAVE OUT ON A.D.
WE'LL SEE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE WAS MISSING AN IMPORTANT
FACT.
WHEN HEALTHY, AND WITH A.D.,
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN EVER BANK ON.
>> IT'S TOUGH.
IS A LOT GOING ON.
LeBRON WAS GETTING IN THE SUPER
BOWL, SUPER BOWL WEEK WAS TURNED
UP.
IT'S HARD.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM GO OUT
LIKE THIS.
I WAS THINKING HE WOULD PLAY 50
GAMES THIS YEAR, GET READY FOR
THE POST SEASON.
WHEN HE DROPS A GAME AND THEY
LOSE, I DON'T GET HAPPY WITH
THAT.
>> I JUST LOVE THAT.
SO GOOD.
HOW SPICY WOULD THIS TAKE BE?
THAT KCP SHOULD HAVE WON THE
FINALS MVP?
>> I HAVE MEMES FOR THAT, HOW HE
WAS LOOKING AT THE FINALS MVP
TROPHY.
I DON'T THINK SO.
LeBRON'S SMART.
LeBRON KNOWS BUBBLE -- EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE BUBBLE, YOU HEARD
THE STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE GETTING
MENTALLY FRAZZLED.
LeBRON GREW UP IN AKRON IN THE
HOOD.
I GET TO STAY IN DISNEY FOR A
MONTH?
>> THE BUBBLE CHAMPIONSHIP, IT
WAS THE HARDEST.
>> VERY ACCURATE.
DISNEY WORLD?
THINK OF JA VAIL McGEE, HE GOT A
STANDARD ROOM, AND HAD TWO GIANT
BEDS THAT HE SLID --
>> EVERY MORNING, SOMEONE IS
LIKE, ROOM SERVICE.
>> HE IS LIKE, LEAVE ME ALONE.
>> OTHER TAKES I'M SEEING IN THE
APP RIGHT NOW, CAPO GOT DEJUICED
23 --
>> CAN YOU SAY IT ONE MORE TIME.
>> I GOT IN TROUBLE.
CAPO GOT DEJUICED.
>> DOES HE HAVE THE JUICE?
>> HEALTHY CLIPPERS IN THE
WESTERN CONFERENCE -- I ASSUME
HE WILL MEANT FINALS.
TRAE YOUNG IS A FRAUDULENT
SUPERSTAR WHO DOESN'T IMPACT
WINNING.
THAT IS SPICY.
>> EVERYONE KNOWS THAT HE IS A
WARRIORS FAN, HE SAYS CRAZY
STUFF.
>> THERE IS BIAS TO THE TAKE.
>> TRAE WENT TO THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE FINALS LAST YEAR.
>> DAMIAN ILL LARD IS NOT A TOP
75 PLAYER ALL TIME OVER VINCE
CARTER AND McGRADY.
>> I LOVE HIM.
YOU LOOK AT DWIGHT AND IT'S
LIKE, WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
WHAT DO WE VALUE THAT HE DOESN'T
MAKE IT?
CHOCOLATE SHOULDERS?
>> DWIGHT SHOULDERS EARLIER IN
HIS CAREER WERE INSANE.
INSANE.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, THERE ARE A
FEW GUYS, ANGTHNY DAVIS IS ONE
OF THOSE GUYS WHERE I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK LATER AND
SAY, DID WE MESS THAT UP?
>> YOU SAY THAT FOR THE 100.
RIGHT?
AND NO DISRESPECT.
HIS CAREER DIDN'T TAKE OFF UNTIL
HE CAME TO LOS ANGELES, AND HE
WAS DOING A LOT OF GREAT STUFF
WITH THE PELICANS.
>> I GOT NERVOUS WHEN THEY PUT
HIS PICTURE UP IN THE MIDDLE.
LIKE, MY BAD, BRO.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LIST,
THEY ARE A POPULARITY CONTEST.
YOU PLAY IN THE SMALL MARKET
TEAMS, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
THE LEVEL OF LOVE.
IF YOU'RE ON THE CLIPPERS, THE
KNICKS, YOU ARE GOING TO BLOW
OUT THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
THEY OVERLOOK AND DEVALUE OTHER
GUYS.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER GUYS
SAID?
GRANT HILL.
>> INJURY WAIVER, MAYBE.
>> BILL WALTON IS ON IT.
HE IS IN THE ANNOUNCER HALL OF
FAME.
WE'RE TAKING TOO MUCH TIME.
NOW, WE HAVE A FINAL FIVE.
FIVE PEOPLE THAT SENT IN 20
SECOND CLIPS.
BY THE WAY, EVERYBODY IN THE BR
APP, IF YOU WANT TO BE ON IT
NEXT TIME, WE WILL PUT IT OUT ON
TWITTER, INSTAGRAM.
SEND IN YOUR BEST 20 SECONDS AND
THAT IS HOW YOU GET ON THE SHOW.
I HAVE NOT SEEN THEM.
YOU HAVE NOT SEEN THEM.
ALL I SAID TO OUR AMAZING STAFF,
MAKE SURE THEY'RE FUN AND SPICY.
FIRST ONE IS ABOUT THE CELTICS
WHO CAME BAKE, BIG WIN LAST
NIGHT.
THE FIRST SUBMISSION TO "TAKE
MASTERS."
>> GO!
WHAT'S UP?
IT'S YOUR BOY, AND MY TOPIC, WHY
THE CELTICS WILL WIN.
THE LAST TEN GAMES, WE WENT 9-1.
JAYSON TATUM AVERAGED 23.9.
BEFORE 2022, WE IN DECEMBER LAST
NINE GAMES OUT OF 14.
SINCE JANUARY 12th, WE WON 15
OUT OF 20, AND ROBERT WILLIAMS
IS LEADING THE NBA IN OFFENSIVE
RATING AND DEFENSIVE RATING, AND
THE CELTICS KEEP PLAYING LIKE
THIS, WE WILL WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
YOU GET THE BALL, AND PAUL
STARTS DRIBBLING, BUZZER BEATER.
>> HE RIPPED A --
>> THAT IS SUCH A TURN AT THE
END I WAS NOT RED FOR.
HE BRICKED IT.
>> BRICKED IT.
>> OKAY, LET ME GO TO SCORING.
ORIGINALITY, DIFFERENT CAMERA
WINNINGS, BOSTON IS WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
HE WOULD HAVE SAID THE ADVANCED
ANALYTICS OF 538.
I'M GOING TO GIVE ORIGINALITY, A
9.
ENERGY, THAT IS A 10.
WHAT IS HIS NAME?
>> CALEB JORDAN.
HE IS LIKE 16 YEARS OLD.
I CONNECTED WITH HIM, DID HIS
PODCAST LAST YEAR.
I'M LIKE, YOU HAVE TOO MUCH
ENERGY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON TV ONE
DAY.
THAT'S A TAKE THAT WILL REALLY
HAPPEN.
>> SPICINESS, I'M GOING TO GIVE
IT AN 8.
THAT MEANS MY FINAL SCORE FOR
HIM I'M GIVING HIM A 9.
DO YOU HAVE MEMES HERE?
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING GRADE
WISE?
>> NO, THAT SHOULD PULL A MEME
UP D.
>> WHEN YOU'RE READY.
>> I WILL GIVE HIM A 10 FOR THE
THINGS YOU MENTIONED.
BUT THE TAKE GETS A ZERO.
THEY'RE NOT WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT HERE?
I'M NOT A CELTICS GUY EITHER.
CELTICS, I HATE YOU TOO.
>> DOES THAT MEAN YOUR SCORE IS
A 5?
TO AVERAGE THE SPICINESS AND THE
FACT IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> HE'S YOUNG, I DON'T WANT TO
BREAK HIS SPIRITS.
I WILL GIVE HIM A 7.
>> HERE I AM, I'M GOING TO BE A
TOUGH JUDGE EARLY ON.
AND I'M LIKE, 9.
CALEB P. JORDAN.
DO YOU THINK HE IS LIKE, I'M
GOING TO DO THE MICHAEL B.
JORDAN AND THROW THE P. IN
THERE?
>> THE FACT HE MISSED HIS SHOT.
>> HE WAS COMFORTABLE WITH THE
NINE.
HE HIT AND IT ZOOMED IN ONLY THE
MISS.
WHICH MEANS HE TOOK MULTIPLE
SHOTS AND CHOSE THAT TAKE.
>> HE WAS A LITTLE JANKY.
I WILL SAY.
>> CALEB P. JORDAN.
I WANT TO CONFIRM.
Y'ALL DIDN'T EDIT THAT.
HE PUT THAT TOGETHER?
HE PUT THAT TOGETHER.
>> HE IS TALENTED.
HE HAS A 13-YAEAR-OLD OR A
14-YEAR-OLD SISTER WHO IS HIS
PRODUCER.
AND I'M LIKE, WHO IS YOUR
PRODUCER AND HE IS LIKE, MY MOM
WORKS HARD.
HE IS A LEGEND.
>> I AM GIVING IT A NINE.
ARE WE ADDING IT UP OR AM I
GIVING IT A 1?
WE GAVE CALEB OUT OF A POSSIBLE
20, A 16.
WHICH IS 80%.
>> HE CAN HOLD HIS HEAD HIGH.
>> ALL FIVE OF THE POTENTIAL
TAKE MASTERS ARE WATCHING RIGHT
NOW, AND I WANT TO YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING GET DOWN TO THE
FINAL TWO, AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A TAKE OFF.
WE WILL DO AN INTERVIEW AT THE
END AND I'M TELLING YOU, EVEN
THOUGH SOMEONE MIGHT GET HIGHER
THAN A 16, THAT DOES -- LIKE,
CALEB COULD HAVE THE HIGHEST
SCORE.
IT DOES NOT MEAN HE IS WINNING.
MAY HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE INTESTINAL FORTITUDE.
>> LET'S TAKE ONE MORE LOOK AT A
MOMENT WE WON'T TOR GET FROM
CALEB.
ONE MORE SHOT.
JUST REALLY SOAK IT IN.
HE HIT THE CIELING, ALMOST.
I DON'T REMEMBER WHO WAS DRAFTED
IN 2018.
>> WITH E ARE DOING SIMPLE SHOW.
I'M NOT TRYING TO DIG DEEP IN
THE ARCHIVES.
>> MAX MYERS, TYLER HERRO IS A
BETTER SCORER THAN DEVIN BOOKER.
MAX MYERS, WHITE OR BLACK.
HE'S WHITE, YEAH.
>> BOOM, I AM GLAD YOU DID NOT
POST THAT FEBRUARY 1st TO 28th.
>> YEAH, THE INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
>> THAT IS A MARCH 2nd TAKE.
NOW, OUR SECOND TAKE.
ALL I KNOW, WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT IS ABOUT THE HEAT AND DRAGIC.
IT'S SPECIFIC.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST STARS IS
HOW GORAN DRAGIC IS IN THE
HIGHEST MEMBER OF THE MIAMI
BRASS.
WHAT IS GORAN DRAGIC, BROUGHT
OUT AND RESIGNED?
IN MIAMI.
HE NEVER HAD A SIT DOWN WITH PAT
RILEY.
HE WANTS TO SHARE THE BALL WITH
A GUY WHO HITS THE BACK OF HIS
HAND.
PAT RILEY HAS HIS INVISIBLE EYE
IN THEIR LOCKER ROOM.
OPEN YOUR THIRD EYE.
>> WOI, THIS MIGHT BE AN OLDER
MOVIE REFERENCE.
BUT IN THE WORDS OF BILLY
MADISON, SLOW DOWN KM?
CAN WE DO THAT?
>> ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE MIAMI HEAT BRASS -- COACH --
>> GORAN DRAGIC IS A SLEEPER
AGENT SABOTEUR FOR THE MIAMI
HEAT.
LET ME BREAK IT DOWN.
NUMBER ONE, LOVE A TAKE LIKE
THIS.
THESE ARE MY FAVORITE PAKS.
PAT REILLY, BECAUSE DRAGIC WAS
LIVING IN MIAMI, HE IS TRYING TO
RUIN THE NETS FROM THE INSIDE
OUT.
ALSO, I CAN BELIEVE IT WITH RAT
RY.
I BELIEVE HE HAS A BUTTON THAT
OPENS THE DOOR AND YOU COME IN,
AND HE HAS ANOTHER BUTTON THAT
WILL DROP NEW A PIT OF SNAKES.
>> EXECUTE ORDER.
>> SECOND THING I LIKE, I FORGOT
ABOUT THE TIME THAT GORAN DRAGIC
SMACKED BEN SIMMONS IN THE BACK
OF THE HEAD.
GREAT CALL BACK.
GOOD REFERENCE.
HE DID THE WORK FOR US.
HE SHOWED US THE SLAP.
I LIKE THAT, THIRD, LOORK AT HI.
GORAN DRAGIC IS NOT ONLY THE
NAME OF A SLEEPER AGENT, HE
LOOKS IT.
HE IS A GUY THAT HAS POWDER IN
YOUR DRINK AND STIRS IT UP AND
FORGETS A LICKS IT.
I'M GOING TEN.
I HAVEN'T HEARD IT.
I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS GREAT.
ENERGY, I LIKE THE WAY HE DID
IT.
I LIKE THE ZOOMING IN.
THE SPEED, THOUGH, I THINK THAT
IS PART OF THE 20 SECOND RULE
THAT WE ESTABLISHED HERE.
I'M GOING TO TAKE HIT ENERGY
DOWN TO AN 8.
AND THE SPICINESS THOUGH, THE
SPICINESS IS A 10.
I SCREWED MYSELF ON THE FIST
ONE.
I REALLY DID.
I WANT TO BRING CALEB DOWN.
>> THIS IS YOUR SHOW.
YOU CAN DO WHAT YOU WANT.
>> I'M GIVING MY FIRST 10.
I'M GIVING MY FIRST 10.
>> THAT IS A MARCH 2nd TEN.
>> YOU COULD NOT HAVE GIVEN THAT
10 FEBRUARY 20th.
I WILL SAY THAT.
>> I AM SO ANGRY AT MYSELF THAT
I DID THAT.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO RULES HERE.
MY FIRST GRADE, I'M CHANGING THE
GRADES.
I'M SORRY, CALEB P. JORDAN, I
MESSED UP.
I WAS ABLE TO CURSE.
I HAD CALEB AT A 9.
I'M SO SORRY, CALEB, I'M MOVING
HIM DOWN TO A 6 AND I'M TAKING
RAGE AGAINST TWIT AND I'M MAKING
HIM AN 8.
THAT MEANS CALEB IS A 14.
PERFECT MEME USAGE.
>> I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
HE SOUNDS LIKE THE MICROMACHINE
GUY.
I KNOW I'M DATING MYSELF.
I CAN SEE THAT HAPPENING.
GORAN DRAGIC SOUNDS LIKE A
HAPPENING MAN.
THERE ARE THINGS GOING.
>> I'M GIVING HIM AN 8.
>> THE KD VERSION WAS MUCH
BETTER.
>> WHAT IS YOUR GRADE.
HOW DO YOU BREAK DOWN WHAT WE
JUST SAW.
>> ORIGINALLY, A 10.
SPICINESS, 10, AND WHAT IS THE
OTHER ONE?
>> ENERGY.
>> ENERGY?
I MEAN, HE WAS PASSIONATE.
I CAN'T GIVE HIM A 10 THOUGH.
I'M GOING TO GIVE HIM A 9.
>> WOW, OKAY.
THAT WAS A BIG ONE.
RAGE AGAINST TWIT.
REALLY PROUD OF YOU.
I TALKED TO YOU BEFORE.
AMAZING.
I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO BRING YOU DOWN.
A 14, AND A 9 AND 8 IS 17.
>> WE WILL MAKE THE TWO TOP
BATTLE OFF TO THE DEATH.
>> THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
CAN. HINK IT CAN'T HURT BUT IT -
>> IT CAN DO DANCHTS OKAY, THAT
IS REALLY GOD.
WE DO HAVE RESPONSES BY THE WAY
TO THE TAKES THUS FAR, TO OUR
FIRST GUY, JAY RICHARD, WHO SAYS
NO SHOT THE CELTICS WIN THE
CHIP, LET AGONE GET TO THE
FINALS.
>> WE GET IT.
>> TRICK VAN EXEL --
>> IF YOU HAVE A GREAT NAME ON
TWITTER, I WILL FOLLOW YOU.
>> GORAN DRAGIC.
J.J. TAYLOR, GORAN WANTS TO WIN
A RING WITH THE NETS NOTCH WAY
HE IS A SLEEPER AGENT.
SEE, THIS IS WHY YOU WEREN'T IN
THE PICKS.
OUR TAKE AGENTS, THE TAKE
MASTERS, THEY HAVE SPICINESS.
THESE IS JUST NORMAL REACTIONS.
OTHER TAKES, MAXEY IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAT THE SIXERS THAN
HARDEN.
THAT IS JUST NOT TRUE.
NOT TRUE.
>> I JUST SOMETIMES WONDER WHAT
BASKETBALL TEAM ARE WATCHING.
NO DISRESPECT TO TYREKE, A
LENLD --
>> THIS IS WHY I LIKE TAKE
MASTERS.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT OUR GUYS
HAVE BEEN SITTING ON THESE TAKES
FOR A LONG TIME.
>> I'M GOING TO TEST YOUR
CONTROL ROOM.
IF THEY HAVE A SHOT OF HIM WHEN
THEY HAVE STARTING LINEUPS --
>> MAXEY?
>> YEAH.
>> I WILL GIVE THEM 26 SECONDS.
>> 26 SECONDS.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY CAN DO IT.
BUT IF THEY HAVE A SHOT --
>> THEY HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE.
>> THEY DIDN'T GIVE HIM A
JERSEY.
STRAIGHT ON.
HE'S LEGENDARY.
I THINK THAT GIVES HIM A HUNGER.
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU ABOUT THE
SIXERS ANYMORE.
I GET TOO EXCITED.
>> I KNOW HOW HAPPY YOU WERE
WHEN THE DEAL WENT DOWN.
BUT I'M LIKE, YO, A MOTIVATED
HARDEN?
>> ONE GUY HAD TWO TRIPLE
DOUBLES IN THREE WEEKS.
THE GOOR IS PLAYING TWITCH.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
>> WHEN YOU DON'T PLAY AT THAT
LEVEL AND YOU WATCH EVERYBODY
ELSE THAT IS NOW IN MID SEASON,
LATE SEASON FORM AND YOU TRY TO
GET IN PRESEASON FORM, IT'S A
LITTLE TOUGH.
NOT KNOCK IT, I THINK THEY CAN
DO WORK AND REALLY HELP WITH THE
DEFENSIVE SIDE AND GIVE HIM
RELIEF WHEN HE COMES BACK.
WE'LL SEE.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT TOP 75 GUYS
EARLIER AND PEOPLE THAT WEREN'T
ON THE LIST.
GOD BLESS YOU.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
I CAN'T BE IN A ROOM WHERE
SOMEONE SNEEDZES AND YOU DON'T
SAY GOD BLESS YOU.
>> LET IT GO.
>> TAKE, IF SOMEBODY SNEEZES ON
THE PLANE, SHOULD YOU SAY GOD
BLESS YOU OR GROSS?
>> THE NASTIEST THING I THINK
YOU CAN DO, IS PEOPLE WHO PULL
THEIR MASK DOWN TO SNEEZE?
>> SNEEZE!
YOU HAVE TO LIVE IN THAT SNOT.
>> YEAH, DO NOT YANK IT DOWN TO
SNEEZE --
>> IF YOU HAVE TO SNEEZE, IS IT
RESPECTFUL TO SNEEZE INSIDE YOUR
HOODIE.
>> YEAH, AND I COME WITH A
CLOROX WIFE, I OVERDUE IT.
THE HEAD REST IS A DIRTIEST PART
OF THE PLANE.
IT'S DIRTIER THAN THE TOILET.
EVERYBODY'S HEAD, ALL THE NASTY
GES.
I WIFE THE BUBLGS DOWN.
>> I WIFE IT DOWN TOO.
HEAD, SHOULDERS, KNEES, TAKES.
THE ONE GUY, KLAY THOMPSON.
APPARENTLY, THE NEXT TAKE, THE
THIRD TAKE, KLAY THOMPSON.
TAKE IT AWAY.
>> CLAY THOMPSON IS THE BEST
SHOOTING GUARD IN THE LEAGUE.
THAT INCLUNDS JAMES HARDEN.
SECOND, THE WARRIORS WILL MAKE
IT TO THE FINALS VERSUS THE NEW
LOOK 76ers AND KLAY THOMPSON
WILL OUTPERFORM HARDEN ON THE
WAY TO HIS FIRST MVP.
>> KLAY THOMPSON WILL OUT -- HE
DROPPED A TRIPLE STACK OF TAKES.
KLAY THOMPSON IS THE BEST
SHOOTING GRD IN THE LEAGUE.
THEY WILL PLAY THE SIXERS IN THE
FINALS AND HE WILL OUTPERFORM
JAMES HARDEN IN THE FINALS AND
WIN MVP.
LE AND THIS IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT,
CHIEF.
>> I WILL LET YOU GO FIRST.
>> I LOVE KLAY THOMPSON.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO SEE HIM
PLAY WITH LeBRON.
NOT PLAYING WITH TWO SEASONS,
BANG OUT FIRST -- YOU KNOW,
FIRST POSSESSION.
HE'S GOING TO NEED A LITTLE
TIME.
I THINK NEXT SEASON, THE TAKE
THAT MAY WELL HAVE LEGS TO IT,
THIS SEASON WILL BE TOUGH.
HE STILL HAS WORK LEFT TO DO TO
GET BACK TO KLAY FORM.
I USED TO SAY -- NO KNOCK TO
STEPH.
KLAY HAS TO GUARD THE BEST GUY
ON THE DEFENSIVE SIDE AND HIT
THEM, AND IF HE CONCENTRATED ON
SCORING LIKE STEPH DOES, HE
WOULD BE DAMN CLOSE.
>> YEAH, WHAT IS YOUR GRID?
.
>> I WILL GIVE IT -- OOH.
MENT.
>> WE'RE IN THE BR APP.
>> I WILL GIVE IT A 7.
IT WAS EGREGIOUS.
>> HIS NAME IS F FLOSSY, 253.
>> EAST BAY IF I HAD TO GUESS.
>> I HAVE ISSUES WITH THIS ONE.
HE PLAYED TO MY SIXERS FANDOM.
BUT THE FIRST THING THAT I TOOK
AWAY FROM THAT, ENERGY'S A 3,
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO BE COOL.
COOL DOES NOT TRANSLATE ON
CAMERA.
IT'S -- THIS IS ABOUT HOT TAKES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT LUKEWARM TAKES,
CHILLING IN A JACK CUZZI TAKES.
3, ENERGY.
ALSO, HE SAID THAT KLAY THOMPSON
WAS THE BEST SHOOTING GRD IN THE
LEAGUE, BETTER THAN JAMES
HARDEN.
I DON'T THINK JAMES HARDEN IS
THE BEST SHOOTING GUARD IN THE
LEAGUE.
>> WHO YOU GOT?
>> LIKE -- I DON'T KNOW THE
POSITIONS PEOPLE PLAY?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> I THINK JAMES HARDEN IS A
POINT GUARD HALF THE TIME.
>> I USED TO SAY LeBRON IS A
POINT GRD, AND PEOPLE COULD GIVE
ME -- THE OFFENSE, LOOK AT THE
TEXTBOOK -- AND THEN HE IS A
POINT FORWARD.
NO, HE IS DOING IT CONSISTENTLY.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO SAY.
>> AND THE THIRD, DOI LIKE THE
SPICINESS OF THE FINAL TAKE.
PICKING A FINALS MATCHUP AND
PICKING SOMEONE WHO WILL WIN THE
FINALS MVP.
DO I THINK THAT IT COULD BE A
WARRIORS/SIXERS FINALS?
ABSOLUTELY.
THE ORIGINALITY OF SAYING IN HIS
COMEBACK SEASON, KLAY IS GOING
TO COME BACK AND WIN FINALS MVP,
THAT IS SPICY, IN MY OPINION,
YOU THINK IT'S UNLIKELY, THE
SUPPOSY METER IS A 10.
TO ME, THE ENERGY, IT BROUGHT IT
DOWN.
I GAVE MY GUY CALEB AND 6, AND I
GOT -- WOW.
>> YOU DID CHANGE CALEB TO A 6.
>> THAT MEANS I HAVE TO BE THE
TOUGH JUDGE AND I'M GIVING HAM
4, AND -- HEY, FLOSSY, I
APPRECIATE --
>> YOU HAVE TO ADD ONE BECAUSE
HIS NAME --
>> WILL GIVE HIM A 5.
>> WHAT DID YOU GIVE?
>> 7 I THINK?
>> THAT'S A 12.
>> NOT FLOSSY ENOUGH, NOT FLOSSY
ENOUGH.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M GLAD I'M GOING
TO BE THE TOUGH JUDGE.
I COULDN'T GIVE OUT 9s AND 10s.
I HAVE TO BE THE A-HOLE.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE THE D WADE
JUDGE.
>> YEAH.
>> FLOSSY, I LIKE THE STRUCTURE
OF IT.
I LIKE THE SPICINESS OF IT.
BUT WE HAD A GUY YELLING AND
SCREAMING AND SHOOTING A
BASKETBALL AND ANOTHER TRYING TO
FIT 1,000 WORDS IN 20 SECONDS.
I LIKE THE ENERGY MORE.
>> NEVER DOUBT PLAYOFF KLAY.
I WILL SAY THAT, AND THE
WARRIORS SQUAD, GET WIDSMAN
BACK, GET DRAYMOND BACK, THEY
WILL BE A PROBLEM.
I WILL TAKE THEM OVER THE SUNS.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS COMING
OUT OF THE WEST.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHO WILL BE
HEALTHY.
>> WHEN THERE'S A REPORT
YESTERDAY THAT MICHAEL PORTER
JR. AND JAMAL MURRAY WILL BE
BACK SOON, LIKE, MAN, AND THEN I
HAVE TO GET INTO -- IS THE
BUBBLE REEL?
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT,
AND JAMAL MURRAY IN THE BUBBLE
WAS A PROBLEM.
>> HARD EGS CHAMPIONSHIP EVER.
>> HE WAS DROPPING 50 POINTS ON
DONVAN MITCHELL.
>> NO HOME GAMES?
AND EVERYBODY IS LIKE, THEY
DIDN'T HAVE BAM -- WHO KCARES?
>> I WILL SAY THE FACT THAT
TYLER HERRO IS GOING TO WIN
SIXTH MAN OF THE YEAR S IT FAIR
THAT SAY THAT VALIDATES THE
CHAMPIONSHIP MORE?
WITH HERRO GOING NUTS IN THE
BUBBLE AND NOT GOOD LAST YEAR,
THAT IS MORE, THE LAKERS FANS
SHOULD BE ROOTING FOR HERO.
>> THEY WERE ALL FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
YOU GET TO SEE THEM IN THE HOTEL
L
LOBBY, HOW DIFFICULT THAT IS.
TO HAVE TO SEE HIM IN THE POOL
AFTERWARDS.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S DIFFICULT.
>> IT IS.
THEY'RE IN YOUR HEAD.
>> NO TRAVEL.
LeBRON'S KNEES CAN'T GET
INFLAMED.
>> EITHER COULD ANYONE ELSE.
>> DID YOU GO TO THE BUBBLE?
>> NO.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO MAKE
ME GO TO ALL-STAR WEEKEND WITH
NO FANS.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEND ME TO THE
EPI CENTER?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY I THOUGHT
YOU WERE REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
BUBBLE.
IN THE MEMES.
>> I'M NOT SPENDING TWO WEEKS IN
A HOTEL ROOM NOT DOING ANYTHING.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT.
GREAT JOB OUT THERE, EVERYBODY.
>> OKAY, WE STARTED OFF THE SHOW
WITH UNINTENDED ZION SLANDER.
>> NO NEED FOR IT.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS TAKE
IS GOING.
IT COULD BE PRO ZION --
>> ZION HAS BEEN HURT --
>> LET THEM DO IT TAKE.
TAKE FOUR.
>> SO I AM HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
ZION WILLIAMSON IS PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE PLAYING FOR THE NEW
ORLEANS PELICANS THIS SEASON OR
EVER GAME.
DAVID GRIFFEN HAS SEVERED THAT
RELATIONSHIP.
IS HE GOING PLAY OR NOT?
T.J. REDICK, PREEM KNOCKING THE
MAN FOR BEGINNING WEIGHT.
BUTFY LIVED IN NEW ORLEANS, I
COULD GAIN WEIGHT TOO.
THE FOOD IS FREAKING AWESOME.
>> IT IS.
>> THE FOOD IS FREAKING AWESOME.
I HAVE SO MANY THOUGHTS.
ZION WILLIAMSON IS NOT GOING TO
BE PLAYING FOR THE PELICANS EVER
AGAIN.
>> YEAH.
WHY WOULDN'T HE?
THEY ARE JUST DISRESPECTING THE
GUY.
>> I'M TRYING TO THINK ABOUT BIG
FIS
FIRST OF ALL, BIG LOW COUNTRY.
WHOSE WAS IT TO PUT ZION IN A
COMMERCIAL FROM THIS ANGLE WITH
A MOUNTAIN DEW AND CHEETOS?
>> A LOT OF TIMES, THEY DON'T
THINK ABOUT THE MEMES.
THEY NEED TO BRING ME UNDER
CONSULT.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO BIG-LOW
COUNTRY.
HE IS WEARING DWYANE WADE'S
OUTFIT FROM LAST NIGHT.
CASUAL SUSPENDERS ON A WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON.
BIG LOW COUNTRY, ALSO
COMPLIMENTED THE FOOD IN NEW
ORLEANS.
BECAUSE IT'S GRE, I LIKE THE
PITCH AT THE END.
MAN, I GOT JOKES AND I JUST
CAN'T FIRE THEM OFF.
I CAN'T DO IT.
>> ZION HITTING MOUNTAIN DEW,
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
MEMES.
ALWAYS TIMELY.
HE WENTS TO GO TO THE KNICKS,
LET HIM REGROUP WITH HIS CREW.
HE HAS R.J. BARRETT OUT THERE.
LET HIM GO TO NEW YORK, GIVE HIM
FREE.
IT'S LIKE, THE THING ABOUT -- I
HAVE BEEN TO NEW ORLEANS A FEW
TIMES.
>> FOR WHO THOUGH?
>> APPARENTLY, THAT POP EYES IS
THE BEST POP EYES KNOWN TO MAN.
I'M GETTING GBISCUITS AND TURNIG
IN.
>> HE'S EATING THE BEN YAPS.
>> YOU CAN MGE IN ZION CAME IN
AND THERE IS POWDER SUGAR ON HIS
JERSEY?
>> IF YOU ARE WILLIAMS, YOU SEE
THE FLOW.
THEY HAVE A BRAINSTORMING
SESSION.
>> REMEMBER IT CAME OUT.
THEY WERE PLAYING THE GM.
REMEMBER HOW IT STARTED.
THE PELICANS WERE TRYING TO WIN
OVER ZION, AND GRIFF WIN WAS
LIKE, COME ON, I'M GOING TO PLAY
THE PIANO.
I HAVE TO FOCUS.
LET ME SEE.
ORIGINALITY, ZION WILL NEVER
PLAY AGAIN.
NOT GOING THAT HIGH.
I FEEL LIKE I HEARD THE TAKE
BEFORE.
I WILL GIVE IT A FOUR.
AGAIN, I'M A TOUGH GRIDDER.
I APOLOGIZE.
ENERGY, MY ENERGY WAS DOWN AND
THEN HE HIT ON THE FOOD IS
GREAT, AND I KIND OF POPPED IT
UP.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH 5 FOR
ENERGY.
SPICINESS, I DO THINK IT'S
SPICY, I WILL GIVE IT A 7.
SO MY OVERALL FOR HIM WILL BE
DWHASH WAS THE LAST ONE?
HIS TAKE -- I HAVE TO GIVE IT A
4.
I'M A TOUGH JUDGE, MAN.
I HAVE TO BE A TOUGH JUDGE.
I'M GIVING IT A 4.
>> I CAN NEVER --
>> I APPRECIATE YOU.
>> THE TAKE, WE HEARD IT.
THE FOOD, DELICIOUS.
>> HE WAS ACCURATE.
ENERGY, HE PERKED UP.
I WANT YOU THINKING ABOUT GUMBO
AND ALL THE BEAUTIFUL THINGS.
>> OYSTERS.
>> SO I WASN'T A BIG OYSTER GUY.
I WASN'T A BIG OYSTER GUY.
IF YOU DON'T -- BLACK PEOPLE EAT
RAW SUSHI, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE HIM A 9.
>> OUR FIRST SINGLE DIGIT, A 9.
ONE TIME IN THE MAKEUP ROOM, ME
AND SHAQ WERE GOING BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT WHETHER FOODS -- HE
WOULD CALL THEM WHITE PEOPLE
FOODS.
YOU WERE THERE THAT WAY.
>> YOU BROKE IT DOWN, I CAME IN
A LITTLE LATE.
I THINK IT WAS MY FIRST TIME.
>> AND WE WERE LIKE, JOLLY
RANCHERS, HE SAID, PURPLE --
WHAT WAS ONE?
BRITNEY, YOU REMEMBER THIS.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT.
>> LET'S DO IT.
RISK IT ALL FOR JOLLY RANKERS.
>> NO, I'M GOING SAY, WATERMELON
JO
JOLLY RANCHERS, BLACK FOOD OR
WHITE FOOD?
>> EVERYONE LOVES WATERMELON.
>> SAY WATERMELON?
>> NO.
>> SHAQ HAD THE DREAD LOCKS AND
SAID, DO THE ACCENT, NO.
>> I'M NOT TRYING TO GET IT IN
REST RANLTS.
CAN'T ORDER FRIED CHICKEN.
I CAN'T DO IT.
THAT'S THE BEST ITEM --
>> I STARTED BECAUSE I SAID,
HAZELNUT CAKE, AND HE SAID,
WHITE PEOPLE FOOD.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN A HAZELNUT
CAKE.
>> HE GOES TO ME, CHOCOLATE ICE
CREAM IS A WHITE PEOPLE FOOD.
>> BLACK PEOPLE DID NOT EAT
CHOCOLATE ICE CREAM.
YOU HAVE NEVER AGAIN TO A BLACK
PERSON'S BIRTHDAY, THE
WEDDING --
>> THE VANILLA GOES --
>> WE USES TO DO THAT AS KIDS.
WHY NOT JUST GET THE VANILLA?
.
IT SOUNDS GREAT.
THREE DIFFERENT ICE CREAMS NO
ONE IS MESSING WITH CHOCOLATE.
>> I WOULD LOVE AN INTERMISSION
ON TAKE MASTERS TO BE FOOD TAKES
AND MAYBE WE GET SHAQ TO RECORD
WHETHER WE THINK HE'S GOING SAY
WHITE PEOPLE FOOD.
>> CHOCOLATE ICE CREAM IS A
BUT BLACK PEOPLE WILL TAKE
VANILLA AND OVERLOAD IT WITH
SYRUP.
>> YOU HAVE ANY OTHER FOOD
TAKES?
>> OYSTERS.
>> WHAT IS THE WORST FOOD EVER?
>> BLACK LICORICE.
>> SUN DRIED TOMATOES, WHY IS
THAT --
>> JAEGER SHOTS.
>> THE GRAETS FOOD EVEN?
>> CHING POT PIE.
>> WOW.
>> HOMEMADE OR THE MARIE
CALENDAR'S?
>> NO, YOU GET TO THE BOTTOM
CRUST AND YOU DON'T NOPE THE
CHEMICALS.
NEXT, DORITOS.
AND POPCORN.
>> YEAH, I WILL PUT IN WORK.
I'M LIKE A LIGHT SKINNED ZION.
>> FAVORITE FOOD?
>> PEACH COBBLER.
I CAN'T HAVE THE FULL PEACHES IN
THERE, I NEED THEM MASHED --
>> YOU WANT TONIGHT BE -- THE
OYSTER RULE.
>> DON'T CHEW YOUR POIS OYSTERS.
>> I'M NOT SEEING THE COMMENTS
IN THE APP ABOUT FOOD TAKES.
OKAY, WE ARE -- WE GOT ZION, WE
HAVE KLAY, WE HAVE GORAN DRAGIC
AND THE CELTICS WHICH MEANS WE
ARE UP TO THE FINAL TAKE OSM THE
SUBMISSION PERIOD.
>> THIS BETTER WILL SPICY.
>> IT'S ABOUT THE MAVERICKS, A
TEAM THAT WENT UP LAST NIGHT.
AND SUDDENLY, JASON KIDD, FORMER
COACH OF THE LAKERS, WHEN THE
DEFENSE WAS AMAZING, IS ON THE
MAVERICKS AND THE DEFENSE IS
AMAZING.
I HOPE I DIDN'T STEAL THE TAKE.
>> I WILL SAY ONE THING.
WHEN -- WHO IS THAT?
>> WHEN THE MOST PHENOMENAL
THINGS I HAVE SEEN.
WHEN THE DRINK SPILLED AT THE
GAME AND PEOPLE WERE WONDERING
IF IT'S JASON KIDD, AND A
GENESIS WITH THEM --
>> OH, MAN THAT CLIP OF JASON
KIDD BUMPING INTO THE CUP, WALK
INTO ME.
OH, MY GOSH.
>> BUEAUTIFUL.
>> WHAT A LEGEND.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE MAVS.
>> I HAVE A TAKE AND IT'S NOT A
HOT ONE.
THE MAVERICKS WILL TAKE IT TO
THE FINALS THIS SEASON.
THEY HAVE ALL IT TAKES TO MAKE A
RUN WITH SIZE, LENGTH,
ATHLETICISM, DEFENSE, COACHING
AND THEY HAVE LUKA DONCIC
RUNNING THE SHOW.
THE WEST IS MORE WINNABLE THAN
EVER.
THEY ARE COMING FOR YOU AND
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN.
>> AND THAT WAS FROM RYAN DRAY,
AND WILL CULT ALL THE TENSION
WITH A KNIFE.
THIS IS JOSIAH'S REACTION.
CAN I TELL YOU, PLAY THE FIRST
TWO SECOND OF THIS.
PLAY THE FIRST FIVE SECOND OF
THE TAKE ONE MORE TIME.
PLEASE.
>> I HAVE A TAKE AND IT'S NOT A
HOT ONE.
>> CUT IT OFF.
CUT IT OFF.
IF YOU ARE COMING ON TO TAKE
MASTERS THIS IS NOT TAKE
SELF-CONSCIOUS.
THIS IS NOT TAKE -- I'M NOT SURE
WHERE I'M GOING TO SETTLE ON
THIS.
YOU CANNOT CUT YOUR OWN TAKE IN
HALF BY GOING -- THIS ISN'T EVEN
HOT.
IT'S NOT EVEN A GOOD TAKE.
>> I WILL SAY HE IS NERVOUS.
HE IS MAKING A VIDEO.
>> DID I THINK, YOU KNOW, WHAT
HE WAS TRYING TO SAY, THIS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN -- OKAY, BUT
I -- I COULDN'T EVEN HEAR THE
REST OF IT.
>> HE IS CONFIDENT.
I HAVE TO CHANGE MY SCORE.
I WAS GOING LOW.
>> BECAUSE I WENT LOW, YOU'RE
GOING TO CODDLE HIM?
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO LIKE ME.
>> OKAY, YOU'RE THE --
>> I WILL GIVE IT A 6.
THIS IS WHY.
IT WAS A GOOD TAKE.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE HARD STARTED
OFF IT'S NOT WHITE.
>> SWHE HAVE HAD -- WE ARE
DEALING WITH PEOPLE --
>> MY DREAM IS THAT SOMEBODY
FORGOT CLIP THE END OF THE
VIDEO.
LIKE, MA, I'M DOING A VIDEO!
AND THEY SEND IT IN BY ACCIDENT.
>> HE REMINDS ME OF MY DAD, MY
DAD DOES NOT KNOW HOW TO CROP
VIDEOS.
>> I AM MOVING IT UP TO A 2.
I FEEL BAD.
>> IT'S A SPICY TAKE.
IF DRAKE WENT AND ENJOYED LUKA.
>> THAT IS POSSIBLE.
BUT THE SQUAD STRUGGLED WITH THE
LAKERS AND THE LAKERS HAVE BEEN
FAIRLY COOKED.
>> THERE ARE TWO TEAMS, THE MAVS
AND THE CELTICS, WE SEE IT EVERY
YEAR, YOU DOMINATE JANUARY,
FEBRUARY, MARCH, AND APRIL, MAY
COMES AND THE REST OF THE TEAMS
HAVE SEEN THE FILM.
THEY FIGURED YOU OUT A LITTLE
BIT AND THE WORTH OF RAY LEWIS,
MOMENTUM IS REAL.
>> YEAH, SFOR SURE.
THE GRIZZLIES, THEY DON'T HAVE
THE PLAYOFF EXPERIENCE THAT IS
NECESSARY.
BUT I'M VERY SCARED OF WHAT IT
WILL BE IN THE NEXT --
>> I WILL SAY, THE TAKE --
>> IN A JERSEY.
>> TO RYAN'S TAKE ABILITY THE
MAVERICKS, IF THE LUKA, J KIDD
RELATIONSHIP IS GOOD.
LUCA IS 23 YEARS OLD, AND 1,000
RETWEETS, THEY MADE IT BIGGER
AND BIGGER.
>> HE USED TO GET IT AT TJ MAXX
AND COME IN THE CLEARANCE RACK.
IT WOULD BE A 5X, WHATEVER.
BUT IF I WORE IT IN 2002, YOU
WERE GETTING NUMBERS AND GETTING
HOLLERED AT.
>> LOOKING AT 2002 FASHION,
PEOPLE WERE LIKE, YOU ARE
WEARING YOUR JERSEY THE CORRECT
WAY?
PUT FALK IN THE FRONT.
OH, MAN.
>> GOODNESS, PHAT FARM.
>> ANY TIME YOU SEE DUDE WEARING
THAT, WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT?
>> LEGEND.
>> I THOUGHT, EITHER HE'S A TIME
TRAVELER OR HE DOESN'T HAVE GOD
FRIENDS OR HE JUST SERVED A BIT.
>> I WANT AN ACADEMICS VELOUR
SUIT FOR MY BIRTHDAY.
WE WERE ALL WEARING IT AND FELT
SO SPECIAL.
>> BEFORE WE GO, LEAPT ME GET A
FEW COMMENTS FROM THE HAPPEN.
WE HAVE FOOD TAKES.
IS GOING TO SERVE AS
INTERMISSION BEFORE WE ANNOUNCE
THE TWO THAT ARE THERE.
JID 1313 SAYS APPLE PIE IS
BETTER NAN STRAWBERRY CHEESE
CAKE.
>> NO ONE IS GOING TO MAKE THAT
DEBATE.
THEY ARE DELIRK.
>> APPLE PIE IS MY TOP THREE
DESSERTS.
KEY LIME PIE --
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT ABOUT YOU.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
ICE CREAM.
>> SURE.
THE YELLOW CAKE WITH A CHOCOLATE
FROSTING.
STRAWBERRY SHORT CAKE, BETTER
THAN CHEESECAKE, AND PEACH
COBBLER.
>> THE OTHER FOOD TAKE.
READY FOR WHATEVER 43.
>> ARE THERE 42 OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE MORE READY FOR WHAT HE
IS --
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE LAUGHING
BECAUSE --
>> WHO IS THE OTHER ONE?
WHO WAS THE ONE YOU -- GOSH.
>> I DON'T REMEMBER.
>> CAP ON THE APP, WHATEVER IT
IS CAPPING ON HIM.
READY FOR WHATEVER, PANCAKES
OVER WAFFLES ALL DAY, I DON'T
CARE.
TAYLOR ROOKS ASKED ME RECENTLY,
RANK THE THREE, PANCAKES,
WAFFLES, FRENCH TOAST.
AND IT'S THE BEST VERSION OF
THEM.
>> IF IT'S A ROSCO'S WHATEVER
THE, IF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
LOS ANGELES, YOU HAVE TO ROCK
WITH A ROSCO'S WAFFLE.
I FEEL LIKE WAFFLING ARE --
PANCAKES ARE LIKE LEFT OVER
BREANCHTH I FEEL LIKE A PESHLGT
FRENCH TOAST, WHEN IT HAS THE
EGG WASH, IT REALLY HITS.
>> IT'S A SLAPPER.
>> I AGREE.
DID HE SAY PANCAKES OR WAFFLES?
I WILL SAY WAFFLES ARE ELEGANT.
BELGIUM WAFFLES.
>> I FEEL LIKE HE STOLE THEM.
SOME DUDE FROM AFRICA.
>> WE JUST SAW IT WITH THE
CHOCOLATE GOING BACK.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SORRY, LETTING YOU KNOW, YOUR
WAFFLES CAN BE TAKEN.
WHICH COUNTRY --
>> MR. ROSCO.
I FEEL LIKE THEY ORIGINATED IN
LOS ANGELES AND SOMEONE TOOK
CREDIT.
>> WE KEEP GOING TO ZION.
SORRY.
>> WHAT KIND OF PO BOY IS IT?
IS IT CATFISH?
SHRIMP?
I SEE ONE LONG STRIP OF MEAT.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
DO YOU THINK ZION EATS A PO BOY
AND THE SHRIMP CALLS OUT AND HE
SAYS, OOH.
>> HE IS A GUY I WOULD NEVER
TRIFLE WITH.
IT'S LIKE, IF HE IS --
>> DID HE JUST SAY TRUFFLE WITH?
OKAY, STOP.
ADAM, STOP.
>> WHY DO THEY MAKE THIS?
WHY DO THEY DO IT?
>> RACISM.
>> THEY MADE IT TO PERFORM FOR
YOU GUYS.
HE'S HURT.
>> THEY HAVE IN THE BACK
TABULATED THE SCORES OF THE FIVE
TAKE MASTERS AND WE HAVE COME
DOWN TO THE FINAL TWO.
THE FINAL TWO WAS, THE CELTICS
AND OUR GUY, WHAT -- WHO WAS THE
GUY?
>> CALEB, KPJ.
>> AND THE HEAT, GORAN DRAGIC,
SLEEPER CELL.
RAGE AGAINST TWIT.
CONGRATULATIONS, CLAP IT UP.
>> AND WE HAVE THEM.
THEY WERE PATIENT ENOUGH TO BE
WITH UGS.
LET EITHER BRING IN THE YOUNG
LEGEND HIMSELF, MY MAN, HOW ARE
YOU?
FIRST, SAY YOUR NAME, SAY WHERE
YOU LIVE, TELL PEOPLE WHERE THEY
CAN FOLLOW YOU.
>> MY SNAM CALEB P. 1Y0RDEN.
I LIVE IN MISSISSIPPI AND YOU
CAN FOLLOW ME ON CALEB P.
JORDAN.
CALEB WITH A K.
I ACTUALLY JUST DROPPED A VIDEO
FIVE SECONDS AGO, REALLY.
>> OKAY.
HOW IS YOUR SISTER DOING?
>> SHE'S GOOD.
SHE IS ACTUALLY IN SCHOOL.
I HAD TO LEAVE SCHOOL --
>> SHOULD YOU HAVE PUT HER ON
WITH YOU.
THAT IS A FREE DAY FROM SCHOOL.
>> RIGHT.
>> KALEB P. JORND, WHAT YOU DID
TAKE?
>> MORE OF A POINT OF ABOUT
ORIGINAL.
YOU HEAR ABOUT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
THE CELTICS, AND THEY WERE LIKE,
OH, MAN, YOU HEAR THEM BRINGING
IN THE SCENARIO AND THEY DID
TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT PEOPLE ON
THE TEAM DON'T REALLY TALK
ABOUT.
>> WERE YOU ANGRY WITH ME WHEN I
LOWERS ERS YOURSELF MINCHT AND
THERE ARE --
>> HE CALLED ME SIR WHEN I DID
HIS SHOW.
GOOD DUDE, HARD WORKER.
I TOLD YOU, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THE FUTURE OF THE GAME.
PICK BETTER TEAMS TO WORK WITH.
>> KALEB, I JUST DECIDED ON THE
SPOT TO FIGURE OUT WHO'S GOING
TO WIN, I WILL GIVE YOU 20
SECONDS TO THINK OF YOUR BEST
FOOD TAKE, AND THAT WILL BE THE
COMPETITION.
I LET YOU THINK ABOUT IT RIGHT
NOW.
AGAIN, SPICY, CREATIVE,
CONFRONTATIONAL.
SOMETHING MAYBE WE SAID.
I WANT IT ON THE SPOT TO SEE HOW
YOU CAN FREE STYLE WITH YOUR
TAKES.
I HAVE VAMPED FOR 15 SECONDS.
WHEN YOU'RE READY, GIVE US YOUR
BEST FOOD TAKE.
>> WOW.
I'M ACTUALLY READY.
HEAR ME OUT.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU GUYS
RIGHT HERE.
ARE BONELESS WINGS WINGS?
>> NO.
>> AND WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
GIVE US YOUR TAKE.
>> THEY'RE NOT WINGS.
THEY'RE NOT WINGS AND THE REASON
I SAY THIS TAKE, EVERYBODY WHO I
ARGUED.
I WANTED TO CLOCK OUT OF WORK
FOR SAYING THERE ARE WINGS.
THE FACT HE SAID IT, I WANTED TO
WROTE MY STEP UP.
THEY'RE NOT WINGS.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE BONES AND YOU
CAN PICTURE UP WITH A NIKE AND
SHORK, THEY ARE CHICKEN NUGGETS.
>> I WILL SAY THEY CLOSER TO
MEEPT AND DON'T DON'T TAKE THAT.
>> KAY LEB P. JORDAN, EVERYBODY.
KALEB, STAY ON THE LINE.
THAT MEANS OUR NEXT CONTESTANT
HAS A LEG UP.
HE HAD MORE TIME.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE HIM AS
MUCH TIME.
RAGE AGAINST TWIT.
GORAN DRAGIC IS A SLEEPER.
LET'S FWHAUM.
RAGE, YOU HEARD OURM WHAT IS
YOUR RESPONSE TO EVERYTHING YOU
HAVE HEARD TODAY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I FEEL LIKE IS
A LOT OF HOME COOKING.
JOSIAH, YOU KNEW THE KID BEFORE
HE CAME ON.
A YOUNG PUCK.
HE SEEMS PROPER.
I WILL GIVE HIM A FOLLOW.
BUT THIS IS HOME COOKING.
YOU SET ME UP.
IS A LOT -- I'M GLAD HE CAME ON
WITH THE SELLECKS TAKE.
THERE IS A LOT OF HEAT
PROPAGANDA GOING ON.
YOUR NETWORK, PUT AND THE
MEMPHIS GAME OVER THE HEAT GAME.
>> THAT IS MY DECISION.
I DID THAT.
>> YOU DID THAT.
I DIDN'T AGREE WITH THAT.
>> YOU ARE PROPAGANDA.
>> I DIDN'T AGREE WITH THAT.
HOW THE DRAG IRK TAKE, A TAKE
YOU HAD FOR A WHILE OR WHEN YOU
SAW IT, YOU ARE LIKE, LET ME
COOK UP A TAKE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
LOT OF HYPE GOING, OF DRAGIC --
A LONG SHOT OF HIM COMING IN AND
YOU SEE, AND YOU ARE LIKE, THIS
IS PROBABLY GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND THE FACT HE WENT TO THE
NETS, IT'S LIKE, THAT'S A.
BE THIS IS A BIGGER PLAN BY PAT
PRY 23E67 AND SO YOU'RE THE
FAVORITE RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE -- AND I BELIEVE IN
23R5I6 AND THAT'S IN THE RANGE
OF POSSIBLE TIPS FLERKS AND DO
YOU THINK HE HAS A FAKE TOOTH
FILLED WITH CYANIDE IF HE IS
FOUND OUT?
>> KEVIN DURANT IS LIKE,
SOMETHING'S FISHY.
>> THE FAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, WHAT IS -- GIVE US
YOUR SPICIEST FOOD TAKE?
>> WELL, FIRST, PANCAKES,
OVERRATED.
BONELESS WINGS ARE WINGS.
IF AS A CHING PRODUCT, IT'S A
WING.
SORRY.
I JUST -- IT'S WINGS.
>> WHAT IF IT'S A CHICKEN LEG?
>> WOW, AND JUST LIKE THAT --
OH, NO!
OLD ON.
WAS THAT GOING TO BE YOUR FOOD
CAKE OR DID YOU HAVE A DIMPBD
ONE?
>> NO, I WILL RESPONSIBILITY TO
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE SHOW.
AND IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL TO GET
PANCAKES.
WHEN YOU PUT UP THAT RAFFLE
MACHINE AND THE MIX, THROW IT
DOWN AND MAKE SURE YOU DIDN'T
GET THE JANKY HAS THE.
>> ANY NOINLT COMMENTS BEFORE WE
PUT YOU ASIDE AND WE FIGURE OUT
WHO WINS.
>> HEAT IN FIVE.
ALL RIGHT, TAKE HIM OFF THE
SCREEN.
>> THAT WAS THE SPICIEST.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
I CAN'T LOOK AT HIS FACE.
I CAN'T BELIBERATE.
OKAY, TAKE MASTERS.
SO I WILL SAY AFTER THE TWO
TAKES, I LIKE THE WAGE AGAINST
TWIT MORE.
CLEARLY, WE GAVE IT A HIGHER
SCORE.
I THOUGHT OUR GUY KPJ DELIVERED
A BEAUTIFUL SOLILOQUY ON WINGS
OFF THE TOP OF HIS HEAD.
I WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINT THE
AGAINST WAGE AGAINST TWIT RIGHT
THERE.
HE HE WENT COUNTER TO YOU AND
YOU HIT HOISM AND I GET IT.
OKAY.
AND SO I'M TURN BECAUSE IN THE
23RE67 STYLE ROUNG, I FEEL FLIK
AND WHAT I'M GOING TO DO, AS A
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL IS LET YOU
MAKE THE DECISION.
>> I KNEW YOU WERE GOING TO DO
THAT TO ME.
>> TO PUT ALL THE PRESSURE ON
JOHNSON.
IF I PICK HIM, I WILL GET AUSED
OF KPLOESM AND ARE WOE GOING TO
DOIM IT DOWN TO A WING TIME
FLINCHTS AND HE LOOKS LIKE THE
TYPE THAT -- HE HAS ALLEGIANCE
BE.
>> OUR AMAZING PRODUCER, 40E6789
AND SFLESMT.
>> SHE IS TAKING GORAN DRAGIC,
SLEEPER CELL.
RAGE AGAINST TWIT.
>> IF WE CAN BELIEVE HER, WE CAN
DO THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS, RAGE AGAINST
TWIT.
YOU WON!
>> KALEB, LET ME GET BACK ON THE
PODCAST.
>> AND KPJ, I WANT TO YOU KNOW,
YOU ARE THE MAN.
YOU ARE AN UP AND COMING.
YOU KILLED IT IN THE FREE STYLE.
BUT RAGE AGAINST TWIT TAKE WAS
TOO GOOD.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY TO THE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO WILL
FOLLOW YOU AFTER THIS
EXPERIENCE?
>> I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE IT'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF PETS GOING
FORWARD.
I'M NOT GOING TO HAPPEN TO 34I7D
AND HE WILL PUT SMUPG AND SNESMT
AND JUST WATCH, WATCH GOING
DNKTS RAGE GEMPBLS AND AUDE DRY,
DO WE STILL HAVE THE OTHER
CONTESTANTS ON THE LINE OR HAVE
THEY DROPPED OFF.
KALEB, CONGRATULATIONS, WE NEED
TO TALK TO YOU AGAIN.
WE LOVE YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING A
PINLIST AND TWRM AND --
>> HE'S A LEGEND.
>> NO --
>> HE IS BREAKING UP.
DUMP HIM.
>> SORRY.
>> WHERE CAN THEY FOLLOW YOU?
KALEB P. JORDAN?
>> YEAH, KALEB P. JORDAN.
LIKE MICHAEL JORDAN.
>> THIS IS YOUR STORY NOW, YEARS
FROM NOW, WE WILL FACE OFF AND
YOU WILL END ME.
THAT IS HOW IT GOES.
>> YEAH, I LOST "TAKE MASTERS"
AFTER I DOMINATED IN THE FREE
STYLE ROUND.
WHAT ARE THE NAMES OF THE OTHER
GUYS.
>> DID RYAN, FLOSSY.
>> HE WAS FLOSSY.
>> BIG LOVE COUNTRY.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
YOUR TAKES WERE REALLY GOOD.
EVERYBODY IN THE APP GIVING THE
TAKES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS WAS "TAKE MASTERS" AND WE
WANT TO DO IT FOR OTHER EVENTS.
WHETHER IT'S THE NFL -- WE HAVE
TO DO A FOOD ONE BY ITSELF.
>> FOR SURE.
>> DO YOU HAVE A NAME ABOUT WHAT
WE EXPERNTSED?
I AFRASM AND HAD SOME PEANUTS
AND ALMONDS.
>> THEY SERVE PEANUTS ON THE
AIRPLANE?
>> YEAH.
>> THE PANDEMIC IS REALLY OVER.
>> THAT IS -- THE FULL RECLINE.
I APPRECIATE YOU PULLING UP.
THANK YOU TO THE CREW, AND
EVERYBODY, AND EVERYBODY DID AN
AMAZING JOB.
>> IT WAS A WELL PLACED SNEEZE.
>> THE TOP TEN SNEEZE I HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN MY LIFE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, I HOPE
WE GECHT AND YOU'RE THE MAN,
LETKO HERE.
THANKS TO EVERYBODY IN THE APP.
THE AMAZE PROGRESS DUCTION CREW
THAT WHIPPED IT UP OUT OF
NOWHERE.
YOU ARE KILLING IT WITH A GREEN
SCREEN, AND IF YOU HAVE TAKES,
BE ON THE LOOK OUT WHEN WE ARE
CALLING OUT FOR THE VIDEOS.
20 SECONDS, THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
TO SHINE.
WE ARE GOING TO REGULAR ALL THE
TAKES AND IF THEY HIT, WE WILL
CELEBRATE YOU, THIS HAS BEEN
"TAKE MASTERS."
HOLLER AT YOU LATER.